So I want to talk a little bit about peepee
funds. You know, when these programs were
put in place, I could have gone out and gotten
peepee money to pay employees and to pay studio
rent. Even though we're not using the studio
right now, we're still paying rent for it
because we have a lease. But when this opportunity
was presented to me, I kind of thought it
through and I realized we are getting hit
because of the virus. A lot of people are
canceling memberships. We're having some advertisers
drop out. YouTube revenue is down, but we're
not really that affected. Like, if I was a
restaurant that was closed, my revenue has
just gone to zero. So I decided there's limited
money. I'm not going to take this this funding.
I'm not going to do it. I'm mean to leave
the money for somebody else. I opted out and
some people in our audience grabbed some memberships
and made up for a little bit of the hole we
were digging out of. We've now learned, because
the data has been released about who received
large amounts of money through this government
bailout program that Khania West's clothing
line has been bailed out.
Scientology, the Church of Scientology took
money. Connew U.S. clothing line was cleared
to receive five million dollars. This is a
billion dollar brand. They receive five million
dollars. The Church of Scientology, which
is so, so wealthy and a major holder of real
estate. And I want to remind people that these
were loans designed in a way where as long
as the loans are used with certain parameters
like to pay for payroll, etc., you don't need
to repay the money. So this these were loans
that are largely forgivable if you use the
money in the prescribed ways. So for churches
and other entities that don't pay taxes, they
aren't paying taxes, which is ultimately where
this money comes from. Right. As money is
coming from government revenues. The taxes
I pay, the taxes you pay. And they are taking
that money. American citizen money. And then
they are receiving it and they're never going
to have to pay it back. And the example I
mean, there's so many examples I could spend
all day just giving you examples. The Soho
House, which is a membership club controlled
by a billionaire named Ron Burkle. They got
loans between nine and 23 million dollars.
They applied for a bunch of loans. They have
different locations in Miami Beach, in Chicago
and New York, et cetera. More than 400 country
clubs and golf resorts got peepee money. The
Ayn Rand Institute, which is all about Ayn
Rand's philosophy about self-sufficiency and
not depending on government. The Ayn Rand
Institute, who we've done work with, we've
we've interviewed people from the Ayn Rand
Institute and I've moderated some debates.
They took money. Remember, Ayn Rand was against
depending on government, but received welfare
benefits. The Ayn Rand Institute, which espouses
her ideology, also got. Peepee, bail out money.
So there's a few different things here. Number
one, this is why we need oversight and this
is why they didn't want oversight at all.
The billionaire developer, Joe Farrell, who
builds mega mansions in the Hamptons, got
a p p p loan of somewhere up to a million
dollars private jet companies which have quickly
rebounded because rich people now, instead
of flying first class or or chartering a private
jet, they're increasingly buying private jet
jets or private jet companies are buying more
jets in order to allow rich people to charter
them. So they very quickly recovered. Private
jet companies got peepee money, including
jet lynx aviation. It's an insanely long list.
But meanwhile, all these small businesses
have failed. Restaurant owners I know in eastern
Massachusetts and in western Massachusetts
and even in other parts of the country, they're
just closing. They're done. They're not coming
back again.
I could have taken some peepee cash to pay
employees and cover studio rent. But because
I decided, you know, we're not that bad off.
We're not that port. We're not we're not that
poorly positioned. I can just kind of go to
my audience and say, listen, a lot of people
had to cancel and maybe you can get a six
dollar a month membership like that was my
ask, because I wanted to do what I thought
was the right thing. So it's very disturbing
to see the way that this has gone down. Of
course, a lot of, you know, it's crony capitalism.
A lot of Trump's friends have gotten huge,
huge money up. But there's also the irony
that the same people who say we shouldn't
be dependent on government are actually the
first in line for the handouts. And a lot
of them are wealthy conservatives. Every broke
and struggling small business owner should
be furious about what's going in, going on.
And, you know, the right loves to claim to
be against socialism, but they're against
it as long as it's not helping poor people.
Right. When when it's not rather when it's
not helping poor people. That was confusing.
When it's not helping poor people, when it's
helping them and their friends, all of a sudden
socialism is OK. And last point on this, if
you know how they always say, well, private
companies are going to do better jobs at things
than the government, if a private company
had screwed up the distribution of peepy funds
this badly, heads would be rolling, people
would be fired. There would be massive penalties.
And meanwhile, the Trump administration is
essentially getting a pass using with no oversight
people money being used as a slush fund for
Trump's friends and other people in positions
of power. It's you know, it's infuriating,
but it's also just really sad and depressing
that this is did we really expect anything
else when Donald Trump when Trump talks about
doing infrastructure spending, he talks about
doing it by handing out contracts to his buddies.
You know, it's there's always some crony capitalist
background to this.
And we're going to continue covering this
over on our Instagram page at David Pakman
show.
So make sure you're following us there. We're
going to take a quick break. I am going to
talk about Mary Trump's book. Coming up next